let's suppose you attend AFM this coming
year or next and you're sitting down
with a friendly first-time filmmaker and
you say you know what I just want to
give you five tips that you absolutely
must know about making your first
feature film first thing I would say um
definitely has which is more of a
producer's job it's still I think having
a budget locked on you have the budget
the financing locked in that you have
all the money you need for the entire
film from pre-production to principal
photography the post-production to
distributing and prints and advertising
the entire everything that is locked in
then to have a set schedule and time
frame on when you want to get this out
this film out there and made and not
layering and taking five or ten years
but having a certain time frame like hey
this is my goal one has done completed
out to the world by this time frame just
also preparation with your scimitar
refer and other people with a shot list
and what you want your vision like kind
of talking to your team prior on this is
what I think for these started seems
should is how they should look is what I
want collaborating with them then also I
think it's huge and really really
important to as a director have a good
working relationship with the cast and
the crew but essentially the cast you're
working with is people on set directing
them on what you want them to do your
vision that's important that you have a
good friendship and working relationship
with them because you're going to spend
a lot of time these people on set and
then even through post-production some
of them I mean you're still talking
community with some of them depending on
the size of the film and then once it
gets out to everybody if you're doing it
the at release your primary issues
I mean heroes gonna come and support the
film so it's good you have a good
working with these people can you
continue to have that so that's
important I think for any director great
that's actually do you think did anyone
sit you down and say the same or this is
all stuff you learned no not it really
adds some experience is my opinion so
good points yeah and definitely working
late should I really touch your base on
that that's huge because if you don't
get along with
actors are some people's director it's
not going to work and I can respect you
it's just not gonna mean they're not put
in they might not put in all their
effort and time into your tea or film
and the scenes and everything you want
so you have to have that respect in the
cast and then you have respective to so
it's a mutual respect within the crow
everybody the collaboration overall it's
what it is in a business sure and it
doesn't maybe mean that they're bad
actors or bad people it just maybe they
didn't want to really do it and if you
do anything with someone who's
half-hearted it did just create right
you want to work with people are
passionate and take direction well but
also you know if they're suggesting I
think what do you think about this and
you open your mind to yeah we can change
that around it that's cool open your
minds to their suggestions and also just
collaborating with them and you know
having that continued on until the
film's out and the public and detailing
instead of container work with these
people over time a long time for a
career
you